I feel so dirty I've Clorox wipes to
find some hand sanitizer okay um oh and
the game the next game starts
immediately because that was a longest
game obviously man okay so I'm four out
of five that was was a very dirty flag
man so we're actually playing the same
line I had previously ah thanks for the
bits people Texas time with more bits
well here's the standings now penguin
with five out of five
okay so opponents Pony play is kind of a
suboptimal line he's fighting for a
sandwich
so yeah 96 I'll play I think the idea
here is to play like C 3 and then a 4
and then probably going for each 5 at
some point it's playing I think a 4
makes sense
can I regardless these these sort of
positions within item B 5 against the
Knights on a6 usually just favors late
because it's very hard to actually
improve the night was it's hiding on to
see 7 game Bishop e2 very natural I
remember starting this with the engine
like these structures and remember
engine was giving some he5 idea don't
know that makes so much sense though
because 95 is a bit more centralized so
clock plays 94 I'll go for this 95
anyway just relieve tension between the
bishops
I'd used to play f3 f3 BAM
black might play off six oh no six runs
into this black might take maybe taking
doesn't look good
I guess 96 or some idea for black trying
like neutralized things
okay I mean after that last game I think
this this is on my structure tab looks
very solid there's this queen those
Queenie gates I guess he wants to play
f6 defending g 6d v is a bit loose I
don't know if I can exploit it
[Music]
yeah I guess he wants to play off 65 and
if if I play off three there's 96 some
lady three could be interesting idea to
play off three as 93 c4 it gets a bit
weird there's also there's a cool idea
to play f3 96 and then 93 immediately
cuz c5 weak I guess they're still c4
there I have nine f2
[Music]
two takes takes some before move let's
go for it I don't want to spend too much
time never play it also may be
considered taking but okay let's go well
I just blunder I just blundered upon
that's so bad I guess I'm still uh
strict from the last game I just plunder
a b5 I forgot that the Queen the Queen
is also tagging b5 which I saw earlier
so I'll try and treat this as a gambit
and play it off like this was all
intentional even though it wasn't maybe
from g4 move me g4 might be might be
what I have to do here what does black
doing on the Queen side
1upon of a g4 blacks up upon our weight
has compensation see this is not at all
like I was trying to play a nice
positional game slowly build things up
but now I'm I'm kind of commit myself to
just try and attack on the Kings side
actually looks okay because uh the file
like some files guaranteed to open if we
trade then h5 is unstoppable if black
doesn't take on g4 then I take on h5 I
[Music]
just want to open the H file play Queen
each two inmates and if I ever see four
then I can return to e5 meanwhile this
Knight is completely out of play the
Queen's not really doing much either
luck plays f6 Wow
so led you have our six is to meet each
Phi with g5 some logic to that I want to
play each six okay so it's it's a line
to calculate I think this is probably
probably a critical moment should take
my time each five
h 5g 5 H 6 there is Bishop Bishop h8 h 7
King f7o but then night-night oh that's
some nice resource 95 wins the Queen so
the king can never move to have 7 most
black throws in c4 but it should be ok
so H 5 g 5 H 6 so there's takes takes so
basically this slide takes King takes
and then then probably Queen H no queen
each two so each 5 g 5 H 6 takes each 7
doesn't work so takes takes I could take
with pawn and then it hits seven which
is nice
it's hard to stop work h8
h 5g 5 each six takes takes King takes
key position then I take its Queen d7
like maybe it in some case like how so
Queen side and try and tackle on the H
file and another case there's g v g5
could be nice
let's go for this I didn't even think to
calculate 5 we're going into this rosin
it's all we care about is rosin look at
rows an attack on the H file anything
crazy Oh Eric Rosen I think this is most
expected takes takes takes and then some
decision to make I don't want to take
with night in and trade queens unless I
do if you're taking is a something to
think about because 96 would be a
threats and that takes d5 would be a
threat yeah so I might actually win back
a pawn with a better endgame question is
is my attack more valuable it's always
it's very difficult sometimes to compare
an attack to an endgame but but with
actually look they look promising but
yeah let's think about this logically so
if takes rook up 7 Queen h2 I think is
winning so there's I take probably Queen
d7 but okay Queen g7 f5 metaphors looks
just crushing
there's really no other option for black
is there's rookie rook 88 rookie Yates
even g5 is a resource hmm this makes you
seven also playable yeah that's kind of
this is very intuitive but yeah I could
have spent a lot more time that just
have to trust some instincts okay so
obviously if Queenie Chu is as a move I
always want to consider in butter okay
chaydez and there's not much I guess it
depends with Locke plays I guess this is
most likely there is even some crazy
like I'm probably not work takes a six
he takes on a six takes on c5 g5
deserves a lot of attention as well so
does f5 Wow
a problem with that five is like nine
afford facilitates between trade which I
don't want even though it still might be
strong Eric Rosen does not like to
castle frankly terrible Rosen knew he'd
win this tournament when he practiced
beating up on me like that
they're trying to identify my resources
here there's a very rich position like
this this rook really wants to be on
each to but it's hard to get to but yeah
maybe maybe it can be relevant somehow
on the a file so Brooke eighty eight's
what am i playing I'll be a fiver g5
maybe yeah maybe g5 should really look
into this g5 Appa that I'm not
threatening not necessarily threatening
to to take
for maybe maybe I just want a Queen's
like castle open the G file if I've
shouldn't be an issue
let's go for this in black okay so if I
play g5 most critical lines probably
takes g6 maybe g6 okay chain takes takes
that looks yeah that looks at least
promising g6 was a cool idea because it
threatens this and if rook h8 then I
take King can't take his Queen a try and
if rook takes I I take Ani sudden
there's also a crazy idea let's imagine
takes I just work eight seven
immediately and then play this and then
then g6 in the end I think black has to
get back a rook there
so there's King g7 here here here and
then rook f7 almost works the line keeps
going actually takes takes Queen h5 I
guess the King can walk out to u6 as
well important to be aware of the the
forcing lines
I really love to make work h7 work but
g6 okay so imagine takes g6 so then work
h7 is a huge threat because if takes
work h7 came here okay chaydez
it says King okay but Queen h5 at some
point just wins
[Music]
and we'll see what black is up to so
goes for this some tempted just just
play g6 immediately cuz I don't see what
blacks doing here Vox probably gonna try
this and then takes rook takes takes and
then takes and then then even like
queenside castling I mean my King looks
shaky the black scheme was way more
shaky and defends the knight anthems
rook g1f I've also moved to consider
it's gonna be a crazy finish regardless
of what happens I was working in rosin
ville Eric Rosen trying to checkmate his
opponent not very nice of him Eric Rosen
playing kramnik chest doesn't need to
Castle damn
okay so f I mean there's there's a few
different ideas here a5 will be a
resource and some of these lines oh also
King takes g6 I have 95 ideas but that's
okay that's never happening King takes
g6 was also just Force mates
see I guess I should just calculate this
rook h8 takes rook takes takes takes
seems very forcing in queenside castling
so I actually don't see in this line
let's imagine were KJ takes takes takes
here Castle queenside takes I don't see
what I evaluate it as I assume it's
winning somehow that's my evaluation
Sakura not sure yeah Eric Rosen better
rents a car and picked this guy up at
3:30 because he's taking the school team
toll rose him Rosen is too good and
we're going to go into it as well see I
have to take so I should consider f5
which yeah 5 might be a nice inclusion
because then guarantees to open that
file and then I Queens I castle and then
the King so three minutes to whine I
find very nice inclusion though winning
a five wins a castle work off one's a
threat
I really wanted to just castle
immediately keep my up on 95 also kind
of crazy move and then castle but let's
go for let's go for this whole thing I'm
not missing anything
a plaque doesn't have any immediate
checks my castle
I just do is some money to rosin rosin
beats me a match
rosin does our web work rosin wins the
tournament game time is very good as
well I gotta beat rosin 10 games in a
row I don't adopt him save money never
too late to castle move 27 basically an
end game but still very sharp link
blocks keen is one of the most developed
pieces Regev one can't really be stopped
and yeah the Queen just cuts off cuts
off the King from finding anything and
you escape paths between these three
pieces I mean they should just it should
just be winning because the Knights how
the play of the Queen's also pretty out
of play and there's good and there's no
good that king is no good okay let's
just be be precise rook okay rook F one
F six is gonna fall or there'll be some
other checks
or I just flag him so King g4 and
Queenie tooth force mate its Queenie -
Queen G - I never get one mates okay
I was very nice skin so I made like one
accidental on a slip losing this pawn
like 93 just lost upon but it worked out
beautifully like G for an attack was
actually very strong okay yeah I'm happy
with the way I'm playing I mean that the
game before this was was a mess but yeah
I really can't complain this game at
least at least after I i blundered this
I I didn't feel good about myself
but did rebound so I'm at five out of
six oh there's one more game after this